both these
players pick a lot of characters
all right and we got eliza
versus armor king
and howard estate
yeah
so this is the thing about chanel just
yeah he he's you know he has the three
he has the three characters alyssa eliza
um
uh and that's athena that he commonly
picks
uh he's definitely done this
intentionally
yeah this is the character i recognize
as like his tekken 7 character though
like i know he's got to safina as well
uh lisa's always been like the old
school main but tekken 7 has primarily
been the eliza for me
but look at the huge 10 second and he's
already taken off 70 off jcr health bar
here
oh it calls out the grab
oh boy
pick it up
jbc right here low dive i'm really
getting anything started back to the
wall
oh try it for the wall splat but gets
blocked
good punish
these 2d characters
yeah
oh man just kick yourself
backing up looking for something yeah
just trying to find the right moment
oh slowly turning things around trying
to get chanel to the wall
[Music]
and since you got that forward three mix
four four three mix up now it's so hard
to find it's like or duck to high like
in the past you would always duck that
high there right there but you know now
that she's got a mid mix you don't
really want to ten seconds he hit him
with the second part
that ex dive kick nice gotta chill good
five seconds what you can do just sleep
on him
roll away lay
i mean it was a good strategy because
arbitrage rate drive is gonna be a
guaranteed throw attempt for a comeback
so get on the floor yep
yeah yeah
chanel with a two-round lead here
against jdcr
jc are not able to get anything really
started yet okay here we go nice
sidewalk great sidewalk
here's the wall
he chained to confirm on hit and now
he's all caught up here he still has a
bar to work with you could steal it
and uh
chanel
no round round that's my favorite clip
in the icf intro by the way of you
saying no round brown i love it it's one
of my favorites uh but you know one of
the things in this set specifically
that
uh chanel is doing right right from the
get go right around one he's forcing
these duck states to frustrate jcr right
like jace i came for the gravity and
chanel's like i'm ducking i'm gonna be
ducking so then later on it said like
i'm not ducking anymore but he he'll
duck for a little bit to make him think
he's gonna extend a duck and any stand
guards yeah so that little mind game
defensively it's it's mixing jcr up you
can see his offense it's like it's a
little bit off like he's like oh he's
gonna stay duck in here so he went for a
minute he's like i'm stand guarding
that's not a big deal uh so jd's got to
figure that out obviously but chanel
looking really really good right now uh
and those small mistakes when jd really
added up there you know like swinging
into the ex dive kick that one situation
uh and at the very end you know i forgot
which party got caught i think it just
to punish into the wall splat off axis
and chanel was just so good to confirm
and just switching up the punish uh
recognize that the wall was going to be
there for the splat so just really well
played by chanel
yeah um i'm guessing uh jcr is probably
gonna
stick with armor king imagine i mean he
does have a dragon off that he can um
bust out but uh yeah i mean no uh i
yeah i've seen him i've seen him play
dragon off not too long ago actually so
he hasn't really
completely switched over to armor king
so it's it is a possibility
i'm i'm really like that was a no round
right he's actually a pick here it was
uh i think he'll stick with arm king but
i wouldn't be surprised the heiachi and
i don't even mean that just because of
like the meme about heihachi whatever
uh but yeah he sticks out with arnold
king here infinite stage is the choice
didn't like dealing with the wall
pressure from eliza uh this is i mean
that's one of the things i think people
you know undervalue about eliza just her
wall mixed the potential with her down
three oh ex ex
yeah or even just the uh the down
forward three which is the jumping
roaming mid wall bounce you know it's
like dude that will be so good
oh all right here multi throws incoming
this is something he definitely did not
go for early because you know was doing
that duck game on him
yeah oh and i sidewalk there
made the slide
all right no more walls now oh a second
time
and those are running high attack that
time uh also eliza you know has very
good wall carry some of the best in the
game actually just people don't really
talk about it the beautiful cop
down there
gonna finish his food
i can't believe jcr did that he took a
risk there very nice you know and if she
now has you know it stayed up in there
that could have been the round
no
a little nice block there
yeah
good job jd
oh man i wonder if he's going for a
super confirm
[Music]
dc are definitely looking like he has
way more control in this match
it doesn't have to deal with like the
walls at all right
yeah he looks way more comfortable
because those like short range dive
kicks short range low docking from game
one
we're such a pain get the pick up here
time went down halfway for rage art yeah
not gonna kill but seven seconds yeah
it's gonna be enough time for jd to come
back in and put some kind of offense on
him chanel has one bar though so he
might see like an ex dive kick for keep
out or something to burn the clock
great oh
i think he did the shoulder
yeah i was crazy
right jc are working on his own role
around brown
okay not again says chanel
it wasn't enough yes oh shoulder the
plus frames
jcr it's blocking
oh here we go can't try to block this
says chanel
there's that forward for neutral too
finally
are you not seeing these diapers that we
saw from game one
yeah oh look at that spacing
jdcr looking in control even with the
light deficit here oh no
and yeah yeah now it was trying to oh i
got a tech catch too girl
let's go jd wow
that's one game i didn't expect that
that was nice uh
but yeah you know the the short range
dive kicks again from game one we
haven't seen any of those and that might
because the infinite stage you know
right there in that situation the very
end though there was a while standing
too from chanel he's trying to find
something like that back back boom
that was clean very very clean yeah it's
definitely way more control in that
match and i think it is definitely a big
part in having that infinite stage where
you know it's also the comfort of being
able to kind of move without you can
move back without thinking about that
right that's that's kind of off your
mind and uh just you could just tell
that that just made him way more
comfortable in that match and he was
able to get the spacing that he wanted
and he's able to do some pretty good
whip punishes there um you know uh
elicit that uh that last width from
chanel uh to uh to get a big punish and
yeah just uh just overall uh look way
more comfortable now that makes me
wonder is chanel going to you know
re-switch the sage and go somewhere else
uh to try to uh you know get those ex
wall slats again and be that threat with
the down three um yeah we'll have to see
yeah it's interesting because i saw that
chad mentioned that chanel is usually
the one who picks infinite stage so
i think in this instance he should pick
a wall state just because the opponent
picked an infinite state you know like
i'm not going to give you what you want
just for that reason right even if it's
what i like i don't want to give you
what you want
yeah and uh looks like here uh yeah
chanel is is picking the uh wall stage
this is really interesting because he's
usually the one who's always picking
that uh infinite zero two the night
stage and uh yeah just seeing this like
he definitely wants that wall
hey
booker t
good block
wow he ducked through but wrong punished
[Music]
perfectly played there from jdcr
what a pickup
yeah man if he converted out of the
stick
[Applause]
this is the armored king specialist
oh
and he got the follow up
ah she knows how to get out
look at this oh okay nice low carry
that looks intense what did we get out
of the wall carry here yep i told you a
wall carries crazy
you got blood meter oh but no just
another
boot there
jdcr not clustered looking on another no
around round here
it's the best of three of course that'll
be pretty good
yeah this is to go to the winner's final
jd can get one more round there's the
correct funny surprise
yes
all right now i'll carry where
got full blood meter now
the jdc are out of there jd is willing
he's willing to take the lows right now
that's the big difference here and
chanel is not hasn't recognized would
finally clip them all right it's not
gonna be the round but it's gonna be
close
sidewall situation beautiful combo
conversion
and a cancel to make sure
chanel on the board here on this last
game
[Music]
i don't think
so use that meter still at the moment i
don't think so
okay finally out no meter for chanel
went through what two throws
oh no spend some hard stay safe on
unblocked get
he was so ready for that
yeah just jabbing he recognized as soon
as he went to meet her he's like
he's like he's gonna burst meter he's
gonna hit hit some blocks with nothing
else i don't care if he doesn't block
i'm going to be ready to jab jd cr
moving to winners final gonna be going
up against invested there later of
course should